hey everyone today i'm going to do a
video on how i'm going to install a
firefox theme uh the mac os 10 theme for
firefox
so first of all i'm going to go to a
popular search engine such as google
where you're going to search to get to
this website is firefox
add-ons that's all you have to search
and the first link will be
add-ons.mozilla.org
click on this link it'll load and it'll
have a mozilla corporation logo
hopefully if you're using firefox and
what i'm going to search first of all go
down to the themes section of the
add-ons and i'm going to search just mac
because i've done this before and
searching mac
along the right hand side first one
that's available to firefox
3.0.5 i believe
3.0.6 for windows is what i'm using
first one available is the mac osx theme
by golf a t so credit goes to him for
this video
and what you're going to do is hit add
to firefox very very simple process
firefox makes it easy
and install now
first it's going to download the theme
and second is going to ask you to
restart firefox it'll open all the tabs
you had before so don't worry about them
run firefox you've applied the theme as
well as save it to your
uh firefox so
opening it up and it is already so all
the bookmarks that you had all the tabs
that you had open already in firefox
will be there
no need to worry about those
and
that's exactly how you install a theme
now if i were to if i actually didn't
like the theme uh say
it was a little too busy for me or
something i didn't like about it just go
to tools
and select add-ons this window will pop
up and you're going to you're going to
scroll down to actually find the add-on
you installed this one was a theme
and mac os 10 theme
and all you have to click install
i actually like this add-on so i'm going
to keep it so i'm going to exit out of
this
and now i can use this add-on whenever i
want if i just want to go back to the
theme i had before
tools and add-ons again click and hit
use theme
restart it one more time
fox will restart and automatically use
um automatically apply the theme that
you just selected
so that's the quick and easy way to get
and apply themes mozilla firefox 3.0
um
if there's any other video tutorials
that you'd like me to do i'm totally
available so go ahead and personal
message me and i'll get to them as soon
as i can thanks for watching peace